[Música]
Bienvenidos a este programa especial de
France 24 sobre Haití un país propenso a
desastres naturales y políticos que se
ha mantenido en un laberinto sin salida
hasta el día de hoy la inseguridad
alimentaria la corrupción los desastres
naturales la violencia por parte de las
pandillas las crisis sanitarias y
políticas se han repetido una y otra vez
en la historia del país caribeño pero
también están las intervenciones
internacionales que han sido polémicas
frente a un estado fallido esto Explica
las protestas y el malestar de la
población que quisiera trazar su propio
rumbo está aquí conmigo en el estudio mi
compañero Álvaro Cordero cronista de
historia Hola Álvaro cuéntanos más sobre
estas intervenciones Hola sandrine Bueno
como comentabas las intervenciones
internacionales han sido muy importantes
en la historia de Haití reciente y no se
puede entender la crisis actual sin
comprender cómo han afectado las
consecuencias de estas intervenciones
durante el último siglo para que tengas
una idea el primer problema de Haití es
que he estado es que ha estado muy cerca
de la órbita de influencia de un país
tan importante como es Estados Unidos y
esta nación es una de las principales
responsables de estas intervenciones Por
ejemplo entre el año 1915 y el 1934
Haití estuvo ocupada por Marines de
Estados Unidos un periodo que
supuestamente serviría para estabilizar
una nación que por ese entonces era
convulsa pero que solamente sirvió para
que esos militares cometieran
violaciones sobre la población y se
realizara un saqueo muy importante a las
arcas públicas haitianas algo que
llevaría a profundizar su crisis y que
más tarde
haría que sufriera varias dictaduras
militares a lo largo de la segunda mitad
del siglo XX Álvaro pero está no fue la
única intervención estadounidense en qué
contexto tuvo lugar la siguiente
efectivamente la siguiente se daría en
octubre de 1994 cuando el expresidente
jeanberg aristied regresó al país junto
con 20.000 soldados internacionales
liderados por Estados Unidos esta
invasión Tuvo una popularidad más alta
que la anterior ya que sirvió para
regresar al poder a un mandatario
democráticamente elegido que había
sufrido un golpe de estado en el año
1991 sin embargo Tuvo una efectividad
limitada al intentar dar estabilidad a
la nación caribeña sandrino y esta Tal
vez es la más recordada de todas estas
intervenciones la protagonizada por la
ONU en 2004 Qué consecuencias tuvo esta
intervención para Haití pues la
intervención de la ONU en 2004 tiene
unas consecuencias un tanto negativas y
desde luego Tuvo una muy mala
popularidad es recordada de forma
negativa por los haitianos ya que este
acto provocó el final del gobierno de
arístid y se dio en un momento muy
convulso en el que las bandas callejeras
tenían cada vez más poder en el país y
en el que el mandatario tenía una
relación peor con Estados Unidos y con
Francia la antigua potencia colonial que
es tan importante en la historia de
Haití Estados Unidos estaba en contra de
que se perdiera el control en Haití y a
través de Naciones Unidas se inició una
invasión que supuestamente tenía el
objetivo de estabilizar Haití sin
embargo los resultados fueron muy
controversiales ya que la misión estuvo
activa entre el año 2004 y el 2017 y en
ese periodo hubo denuncias de asesinatos
en las calles en esa lucha contra las
bandas armadas discriminación a las
poblaciones más pobres y violaciones
también a esas personas Incluso se culpa
a la ONU de ser responsable de traer al
país un brote de cólera que contaminó
buena parte de las aguas que toman los
haitianos y que siguen Sufriendo a día
de hoy por estas razones sanderín cuando
se habla de la posibilidad de una nueva
intervención internacional en la en la
crisis de seguridad actual que vive el
país por las por las pandillas la gente
es tan reticente a apoyarla en Haití la
historia nos dice que estas
intervenciones no han tenido un
desenlace positivo y que lejos de ayudar
son parte de los problemas que sufre
esta nación
Muchas gracias Álvaro por estar con
nosotros en este especial Muchas gracias
a ti sanderín el país no tiene jefe de
gobierno desde el magnicidio demuis el
parlamento ha perdido poder y las
pandillas controlan el 60% de la capital
estos grupos delictivos han dominado el
país desde hace más de una década pero
su control se ha extendido en los
últimos años Estados Unidos sancionó a
dos políticos haitianos por
presuntamente brindar apoyo financiero y
operativo a las bandas armadas que
amenazan la seguridad existen más de 200
pandillas controlando el país pero este
muestra las más poderosas que se han
adueñado de gran parte de la capital
show y yo controla el barrio marxisón
saliendo de Puerto Príncipe 400 magos
dos se tomó qua de buque un barrio que
queda más hacia el norte de la ciudad
saliendo hacia República Dominicana por
shimani al oeste está la banda g9 Se
tomaron el punto más estratégico de la
ciudad donde están los principales
puertos del país tienen también
controlado el barrio sites zuley El más
peligroso del territorio la banda ocupa
una pequeña parte al suroeste y es donde
se han presentado más enfrentamientos
por territorio en la ciudad cada vez
ocupan más la zona que le pertenece a la
pandilla g9
el balance de la violencia ha sido
devastador entre enero y principios de
diciembre según la red Nacional de
defensa de Derechos Humanos en Haití
hubo mil cuatrocientos cuarenta y ocho
asesinatos que fueron reportados mil
cinco secuestros estas cifras de los
secuestros no reflejan la cantidad de
víctimas solo se contabiliza la
ocurrencia del fenómeno los secuestros
son la mayoría de veces colectivos
también más de 100 mujeres abusadas
sexualmente entre ellas menores de edad
la red Nacional de defensa de Derechos
Humanos sigue trabajando con las
víctimas de violencia para hacer el
balance final de 2022 ya que aún hay
crímenes sin reportar
tras el caos que vive el país el Primer
Ministro pidió una intervención
internacional declaración que despertó
una ola de protestas en la capital el 5
de octubre de 2022
le pido a toda la comunidad
internacional a todos los países amigos
de Haití que puedan contribuir al país
No
ayúdenos a combatir la crisis
humanitaria les pido ayuda
acompañamiento y Socorro
la ayuda que sea necesaria para evitar
las muertes masivas en Haití
la propuesta del Primer Ministro ha sido
respaldada por el secretario general de
la ONU una de las soluciones planteadas
es Llamar a elecciones presidenciales
pero la seguridad del país supone un
reto aún mayor Andrés triviño nos cuenta
sobre la situación política en el país
caribeño
en cuanto a Haití existe una situación
dramática en octubre de 2022 el
secretario general de la ONU transmitió
la petición de agel Ángel y al Consejo
de Seguridad acerca de enviar una Fuerza
Armada internacional para tomar el
control del país debido a la violencia
de las pandillas los cálculos de las
autoridades estadounidenses señalan que
se requiere la presencia de unos 2.500
efectivos militares sin embargo el
gobierno de Joe biden no ha logrado el
apoyo de ningún otro país
tal y como lo ordena la carta
necesitamos movilizar los recursos y el
poder de este consejo y de las Naciones
Unidas en general
la situación de violencia ha
incrementado la salida de ciudadanos a
otros países la guardia costera de
Estados Unidos reportó Un aumento del
458% de haitianos interceptados en el
mar Caribe entre octubre de 2021 y
septiembre de 2022 aunque se teme que
ocurra una oleada migratoria mayor si
arriban las tropas estadounidenses
organizaciones internacionales
juegan por un diálogo
Ay este actores y referentes que tienen
la voluntad de este en todo el arco eh
que recorrimos en todos los sectores
este una voluntad para generar un
acuerdo de transición pero la
institucionalidad del gobierno haitiano
no está en su mejor momento aún no ha
sido definida la fecha para las
elecciones luego del asesinato de
giovenelmois ocurrido en 2021 la
violencia entre otros factores no deja
avanzar con los comicios y organizar
organizar elecciones en el país ahora
por este momento es una cosa muy difícil
dime como usted va a organizar
elecciones en un país donde
hay hay en mayoría de los barrios hay
muchos grupos de controlan todo el país
las últimas elecciones presidenciales
efectuadas se celebraron el 20 de
noviembre de 2016 donde Moisés obtuvo El
Triunfo con apenas un 18% de
participación lo cual desató días de
actualmente la figura de ag y el angeli
como presidente de la república Aviva el
descontento de los haitianos por no
haber sido elegido por voto popular
el país debe tener debe tener un poder
de dos cabezas un presidente y un Primer
Ministro según la Constitución y en este
momento hay solo un nombre que se llama
que tiene todo el poder entre su mano la
situación política parece estar lejos de
tener solución mientras 4.7 millones de
haitianos de los Casi 11 y medio que
habitan el país se encuentran en una
situación de hambre extrema agravada por
un rebrote de cólera que deja más de 180
muertos desde octubre
para analizar más sobre la situación
humanitaria conversamos con Audrey
richarterson quien está en la ciudad de
Puerto Príncipe Ella es la representante
especial adjunta de la ONU en Haití
en este momento muchos haitianos están
enfrentando niveles difíciles de
violencia de hecho el 60% de la capital
está bajo el control de las pandillas la
población tiene que enfrentar la
violencia a diario lo que les dificulta
el acceso a sus necesidades es decir a
la salud a la educación el acceso a agua
potable en el momento hay de nuevo una
crisis sanitaria con el cólera en el
país y esto quiere decir por supuesto
que los haitianos no pueden circular
para ir a sus trabajos el país se
enfrenta la inflación bajo el valor de
la moneda local los haitianos
particularmente en barrios vulnerables
tienen dificultades para retomar sus
vidas de hecho enfrentan la violencia el
hambre Entonces los haitianos muchos
esperan retomar sus vidas con normalidad
poder enviar a sus hijos al colegio hay
algunos colegios que ya retomaron las
clases sobre todo hacia el sur del país
hacia el norte aún hay un buen número de
colegios que no retomaron las clases en
la solo hay un 30 o 40% de los colegios
abiertos pero a muchos haitianos les
gustaría volver a sus vidas con
normalidad Volver al trabajo llevar a
sus hijos al colegio poder proveer
alimentos para sus familias y poder
circular por toda la ciudad con libertad
sin ser atacados por las pandillas sin
estar en medio de las pandillas o correr
el riesgo de ser secuestrados
Mientras tanto en el país la violencia
no cesa carece de un gobierno y continúa
la arbitrariedad policial la ONU anunció
que se podría aplicar un paquete de
sanciones al gobierno para el 2023 sin
embargo no hay fecha que convoque a
elecciones presidenciales hasta el día
de hoy Haití sigue más pobre y olvidada
que nunca Los invito a ver nuestro
especial digital de fin de año realizado
por Julián Ramírez en la página web
France 24.com donde tenemos testimonios
y más información sobre el país siga con
nosotros
[Música]